.
Olivier Bachand.
on fabrique des moules
et des pièces de plast
Le propriétaire, Léo Hurtubise,
va bientôt lancer une deuxième
entrepdes masques chirurgicaux .
- Ça, c'est des échantillons
qu'on a fait faire sur
nos équipements quiion.
- Si tout va bien,
embauchera des dizaines
de personnes.
LÉO HURTUBISE, VP, développement
des affaires, Lava
avoir besoin pour gérer toute
la patente, on va avoir àa avoiu
près une soixantaine d'employés.
- Merci...
- C'est pour rec que HEC Montrél
annonce la création de l'École
des dirigeants des Premières
Nations, une initiative lancée
deux diplômés autochtonesde l'é.
MANON JEANOTTE, co-initiatrice,
École dir. Premières Nationst u,
de réaliser la première école
des dirigeants des Premières
Nations.
dans le nouveau bâtiment
des HEC au centre-ville,
en ligne et au sein même
Des formations intensives
jours, données en français
et en anglais, permettront
- On a la moitiéteurs
qui viennent des Premières
Nations et la moitié qui
et ce sera en co-teaching.
- Les premiers cours seront
Une quinzaine de personnes
sont inscrites.
Les élus et les gestionnaires
des conseils de bande seront
suivront les entrepreneurs.
On esp l'initiative
permettra l'émergence
d'un Québec Inc. autochtone,
les HEC l'ont fait
avec les francophones,ne certai.
Le développement des ressources
naturelles pourrait en être
le fer de lance.
dirigeants des Premières Nations
- La formation qu'ils vont
recevoir, ça va aider les gens
à mieux être prêts à faire face
bénéficier des retombées, parce
qu'il y a des contrats, il
des opportunités d'affaires.
GHILSAIN PICARD, chef, Assemblée
- Ça va être excessivement
bénéfique, parce
permet à une société ou à une
civilisation de se développer. ,
les entrepreneurs autochtones
doivent aussi combattre
les préjugés. Quand Léo
Hurtubires à une agence
gouvernementale, il s'est fait
répondre ceci :pas
mieux de faire des couvertes moa
qui est traditionnel.
sera primordiale pour nouer
des alliances et permettre
l'essor de l'entrepreunariat
autochtone.hand,
Radio-Canada, K